let's tell the jury about hicksville may
2013.
can you tell the jury what transpired at
hicksville
uh it is um
it's a
like a fancy
um trailer park he just started smashing
things um
he picked up something on the table and
threw it right into the glass cabinet
he hit with his hand
a a wall sconce
he cleared the table top on the little
fold down
like kitchen
dining room area in this trailer i mean
it's a trailer
so there's only so much you can do
and he's screaming at me
screaming at me
um
and i i uh eventually go back into the
back
the bedroom area
uh
he comes into the bedroom area we had
what i can only describe as
a
it sounded like nonsense from him it
wasn't making sense
i realized that he's just probably
really high
because it wasn't making sense anymore
it wasn't like a direct accusation i
wasn't he wasn't hearing me when i was
saying i i i
wasn't involved wasn't cheating on him i
wasn't secretly trying to engage this
woman
and some sort of sexual affair
and and then it became clear to me he
was like looking for something he
um
cleared things off the bed
i went into the bathroom
and as i come out
um he's at he asked me where it is
and how long i've been hiding it
i was like what are you talking about
and he says you know what i'm talking
about you know what i'm talking about be
honest with me
where are you hiding it and he kind of
like makes to look into the bathroom
um and i gestured to the bathroom which
is to my right i kind of like gestured
to him and i said like
what am i where am i good at what am i
hiding and where am i going to hide it
and and we're standing in this little
hallway area outside of the bathroom and
he starts
you know
what it feels like patting me down or
saying he's patting me down i can't
recall but
he ripped my dress
the
strap top part of my dress
i had just dyed this thing
myself pink and i
it's just one of those things i
was like
you know that's my
just finished that dress
and um he's like grabbing my my my
breasts he's touching my thighs
and he rips my underwear off
and then
he
proceeds to do a cavity search
he was looking he said he was looking
for his drugs his cocaine his coke
i was wondering how i somebody who
didn't do cocaine
and was against it
that was in and of itself causing
problems in our relationship
how could i hide why would i hide
his drugs from like like he was
insinuating that i was doing it or
something it made no sense
and
he was telling me we're doing we're good
we're gonna conduct a cavity search
shall we
like
just shut his fingers inside me
let's take you to july 9 2013
did there come a time that you went for
a ride on you went to the bahamas and
went on a ride
the yacht with johnny and his kids
well it's less like a
we flew out to the bahamas to his island
he was selling the yacht to jk rowling
and he wanted to kind of have a goodbye
trip on the yacht so it was docked off
the island and i went with him
and his
kids who i
had quickly developed a bond with and
loved and
we brought a friend along with us i
think to kind of
help
and
yeah
okay
tell tell the jury what happened on that
trip
johnny was uh upset that he had to sell
the boat
uh and he was
off the wagon again
but he didn't want to tell his kids so
he was hiding it from them
uh he was putting it in um coffee cups
and drinking and the behavior just kind
of like he was upset he was emotional
and it just he just
you know that's how he dealt with it
just drink
but there's just no off button with
johnny so he just kept drinking and the
behavior kept getting more obviously
drunk and lily rose his daughter at the
time was young
just like maybe 14.
and she started to
um
get panicky
and asked started to ask me questions
about his drinking objection hearsay
without saying what lily rose was saying
please continue on
the objection thank you so she was
asking me questions about the drinking
um and was very upset in the objection
yeah you can't say what lily rose said
but you can you can tell gestures you
can tell and you can say what you and mr
depp said okay
sorry um
so
she was upset and uh
johnny kind of
we were with the kids and he kind of
threw himself off the boat in a
half playful way
um like a dead
he like dead fish kind of way i don't
know how to describe it almost like a
belly flop but
we were on a skip like a smaller boat
parked next to the yacht and he's
jumping
well he jumped off the front of it but
kind of in a
face
chest forward way like
it looked a little scary like not
something somebody would do
if they're completely okay you know it
was
it was
started off all of us kind of taking
turns jumping off the edge of the yacht
into the water and then he
at one point kind of throws himself over
and it looked a little scary
um
the way his body fell into the water and
lily rose um
started to cry
and
expressed to me that she objection here
is
sustained you you can't say what she
said you can say you can
tell expressions or observations but you
can't say what lily rose said
so lily rose is crying
and then the crying becomes like um
like a panic
like like almost like a panic attack uh
it like rapid breathing
crying
lots of questions
and i'm holding her kind of comforting
her and johnny comes in
and within a few
[Music]
within a few seconds i realize that he
you know kind of shifted his attention
on me and then he
seemed very angry
he asked lily rose to leave
lily rose
leaves
looks at me leaves crying
and johnny
in
i don't remember the word to use but
starts accusing me of kind of
like telling on him
and
calling him um
uh you know a drunk in front of his kids
i hadn't i hadn't done that
i was actually trying to protect johnny
uh
i wasn't it didn't feel like my place at
all to share that with with his daughter
or anyone
at the time other than adults who might
help with it but not his kids
so
i was trying to tell him i'm
i was just trying to comfort her i was
trying to protect you
he uh
basically was accusing me of doing this
thing and
of of making them aware of his
uh that he was drinking again
and he slams me up against the the side
wall of the bedroom of the camp we were
in the bedroom this whole time but up
against the wall of the cabin
and slams me up by my neck
and holds me there for a second and
tells me that he he could kill me when i
saw lily rose again we get
uh
i won't say what she told me but the
next thing we do is we call for a
helicopter to come and take us off of
the
um boat or off of the island so we leave
the boat go to the
landing um of a a part of the island or
maybe it was a different you know island
we had to get to to leave and we
we take off i'm holding lily rose in my
i'm
literally holding her under my arm while
she's crying and we're lifting off and
jack ended up not coming with us at the
last minute he stayed
behind um
and we were taking off and i
remember being really torn about leaving
i
i i felt bad about leaving even though
that
that that had happened i still felt
awful leaving i felt awful leaving him i
i i also felt like
i had done something wrong you know
like he was mad at me i wasn't
sure you know
what i had done but i i remember not
being you know i'm getting all these
text messages from him calling me all
these names and
it was barely coherent barely and i'm
holding his daughter crying
you